forget your cape heroes on austere
prestige dramas the most auspicious
franchise season is here again
the fast saga has blessed us with a
trailer for its latest iteration the 9th
Fast & Furious film aptly titled f9
there's more to the trailer than meets
the eye it's impossible to talk about
the f9 trailer and not talk about Han Lu
if you're a casual viewer of the past
and Furious franchise or you're still
catching up on it you might need some
context the end of the trailer features
a Korean man walking in and munching on
the snack that would be Han Liu played
by Sung Kang who has presumably been
recovering from getting killed in an
earlier movie how does it the center of
a mildly confusing timeline ship that
the Fast and Furious franchise made as
it was hitting the metaphorical nas
button the character was introduced and
subsequently died in what appears to be
a street racing crash during 2006 is
fast and furious
Tokyo Drift fajans presidents proved to
be so beloved by fans that the character
was included in the fourth fifth and
sixth films the canonical timeline was
rearranged so that Tokyo Drift actually
takes place after the events of Fast &
Furious 6
the mid-credits scene the past six shows
the exact scene from Tokyo Drift in
which Han dies but reveals the crash to
be an intentional act by Deckard Shaw
since Hans death and the later
rehabilitation of Deckard is a good guy
the hashtag justice for Han became
popular online for two reasons one the
character is deeply missed and two
because it's more than a little unfair
that his killer is now buddy-buddy with
team Dom Justice is coming according to
the trailer and we couldn't be more
excited we couldn't be happier to see
that Helen Mirren is reprising her role
as Magdalene Shaw once again after the
character first appeared it pay to the
Furious and then cameo danhobson Shaw
if you missed her most recent appearance
in Hobson's Shaw you might not know that
Magdalene was sprung out of prison by
Deckard and Hattie two of her three
children unfortunately due to the
productions of Hobbes and Shaw and f9
overlapping neither Deckard nor Hattie
will be joining the team in f9 their new
best friend forever Dwayne Johnson's
Luke Hobbs will likewise not be
appearing in f9o and Shaw however might
be a different story originally the
major antagonist of f6o and ended up in
a hospital after Dom's crew did a number
on him that stay in the hospital was
what originally motivated big brother
to kill Han and swear vengeance on Tom's
family before ultimately breaking bread
with them and faded the Furious the
riders for Fast and Furious 9 have
obliquely teased that Owen might be
ready to rumble again beyond his brief
cameo and pay to the Furious though they
didn't specify when it's entirely
possible he'll skip ahead to appear in
Fast in the Furious 10 instead which is
already in pre-production still his
possible appearance is something to keep
in mind as the story revs up as the f9
trailer reveals DOM and Mia Toretto have
a secret brother now Jacob in fact
director Justin Lin is returning to the
franchise after sitting out for the
seventh and eighth films precisely
because he wanted to invert the trope of
found family in the Fast and Furious
franchise as he told Entertainment
Weekly when I left after fast six I
really thought that was it like there's
no more fast stories I can tell then two
years ago I woke up with an idea for the
new chapter and a big part of that is
exploring the steam of family that is
always tied to fast but doing it through
blood you don't turn your back on them
even when they do given all the new
familial surprises in f9 it looks like
there's never been a better time for
Dom's sister Mia Toretto to make a full
return to the front lines at the Fast
franchise we last saw Mia in action back
in Fast & Furious 6 but she took a
backseat in Furious 7 due to her second
pregnancy rather than battle super spies
she stayed in the Dominican Republic
while the rest of the family drove cars
through skyscrapers things became
complicated following the sudden and
tragic death of Paul Walker in 2013
halfway through production of Furious 7
an entire coda was added to the end of
the film to celebrate Walker's life
through his character Brian and his
relationship to Mia as part of the
overarching story since Mia's character
is so entwined with Brian she didn't
appear in faded a furious under the
guise of the two wanting a quieter safer
life with their children the entire
franchise has had a period of
readjustment since Walker's loss and
Mia's place within Canon represents the
biggest challenge of all how do you ride
around the fact that Mia gets to go on
big super heroic car adventures and
Brian doesn't apparently the answer
involves giving her and Tom a secret
deep slash assassin brother played by
John Cena
this bombastic trailer has plenty of
details to pour over but it's definitely
not revealing everything
for one thing Michael Rooker is nowhere
to be found the veteran character actor
was confirmed to be joining the cast way
back in August 2009 teen it's odd that a
character enjoying a nice career high
thanks to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
wasn't featured in a trailer for another
massive franchise all we know for
certain is that his character's name is
buddy
and that Rooker was cast in the last
minute as production was set to begin
considering the timing it's possible he
replaced an actor whose availability
suddenly fell through from there we can
only speculate will he be playing Dom
Mia and Jacobs father some sort of new
henchmen to Charlize Theron s bill and a
cipher or maybe he'll simply be a
helpful car mechanic to get the past
family back on the road one thing's for
sure though you have a saying the enemy
of my enemy is my friend
I don't have friends I got family check
out one of our newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]